Alana
do you feel bad knowing that children will bear the brand of climate change
I totally do see why this is so funny
but also I have like some very serious and real points to make about this
because I had this conversation the other day and it was really annoying
and I won the debate
and I wanna tell you some of the things I said because inevitably
like this is I know that this is conversation that other people will be having
not just me I was like drinking
having nice girls night with some girls who like late 30s
not having kids like decide not to have kids
um which is awesome
and like they
I told them like I wanted to have like a baby and they were really critical
and they were saying like
why would you bring a baby into this world
climate change
like the world is burning
none of which I disagree with in terms of the world burning
but it didn't change my mind
and I was like well
you know what women
like again our reproductive systems are becoming political
like our bodies are political playgrounds
we know that we are still somehow in 2024 fighting for like abortion rights
like rights to choose
rights to access basic healthcare has been practiced for a very long time
the abortion one is just like such an easy one to point to
but there is like
so many different ways that our bodies are political playgrounds
and our reproductive systems and our reproductive potential is just like
constantly common question
we can't win with her like a single mum
we can't win with her don't have babies
can't win with her do have babies
can't mother properly just like
just like a never ending like set of judgement
climate crisis
let's point to the women to solve it
did you know that
having a baby is the worst possible thing you can do for the world
in terms of like you can like become a vegan and you can recycle all you want
and you can like ride your bike everywhere
but if you have a baby undoes all that
are men getting that type of judgement
you know what it doesn't matter because maybe they are
and this what I'll say
that women are the ones who are socialized and conditioned from birth
to give birth they are told a whole life
you will find fulfillment
you will be a real woman if you have a baby and re
and fulfill your reproductive potential
that will be the most amazing thing that you ever achieve in your life
it is drilled into us it is drilled into us right
and we are told to accept that reality whether or not we want to
both things being valid whether or not we want to
that is it and like we are criticized if we choose a different path right
we are you cannot argue we are conditioned we are told
we are told in multiple ways from our families
from the media from politics
from friends that societies
everything
we're told this is what you'll do and it'll be great and you'll be a woman
it'll be amazing and if you don't do it has to be this whole thing
why I'm not doing it then the climate crisis happens
and then we're told oh
my God if you have a baby
you are the most selfish woman for having a baby
that men are not told the same message like
so yes
we might criticize men as well for starting a family now
but they are not the ones who will suffer as much at the hands of the criticism
just the way that they don't suffer as much um
when they are single dads or just dads
they get a lot more kudos for a lot less
so why are we now turning around climate crisis
let's look at women's bodies to solve the climate crisis
I think not I don't think we should do that
I don't think we should go down that route
because at the end of the day
it's just another way of controlling women
and putting the owners on women to solve a problem that men started
and created the climate crisis
men created the wars
so why should I deny myself and my body the one thing I've always wanted to do
whether or not I know that I wanna do it
because I've been so socially conditioned into thinking I wanna do it
I don't even know but what I do know is that I want it
and why should I not to get to have that one thing I want
because of all these problems men started
cause that sounds to me like victim blaming
and that's what I think about that
what do you think so it's like in part of the world
women can't choose like in parts of America
women countries
in a lot of countries in a lot of cultures
women cannot choose discount for a lot of the struggle and the pain that women
who are forced to give birth
and forced to have babies also go through
like it acts as if we live in that world
we don't live in that world
like we don't live in a world where
this is not still a contentious issue
where some women are forced to give birth and for variety reasons
assault abortion laws
contraceptive access resources to information education
we don't live in a world where that's more still an ongoing problem
and maybe when we live in that world
let's have that conversation
we live in a world where birth and babies is very much still
something that happens to women
not for women and then people wanna turn around and be like
well judgemental about why I'm having one
men are already judged and forced and coerced into doing it
and now we're also being the same into not doing it for different reasons
then people say well
like you wanna give birth
but you're talking about like all the women in the world who like
can't choose to give birth
and like
how becoming a mother and all that social conditioning is like patriarchal
but then you wanna go and do it
you're missing the whole point
okay let listen
this is why we have been giving birth before the patriarchy ever existed
it is something we have been doing for literally ever
obviously men
the patriarchy did not invent giving birth
they wanna control it
cause it's the one thing that we have that we do that they don't get to
what they try to control obviously
but they we do it
they wanna control how we do it
they wanna control when we do it
they wanna control if we do it
the conditions under which we do it
but we do it and we've always been doing it
the patriarchy does not own women and people with uteruses
giving birth and having children
they want to but we've been doing it for a long time
long time
before the agricultural revolution and the concept of virginity was invented
the concept of marriage was invented in order to control patriarchal bloodlines
we've been doing it for a long time before that
we've been doing it since matriarchy
we've been doing it for a very long time very
very long time I cannot stress this point enough to me
choosing to do that is not a patriarchal choice
I am not somehow like and like
don't think that your choice to be child free is like
being a feminist hero either
it's not being child free is not inherently feminist
just as having a baby is not inherently feminist
being able to live in a world
free from structures that dictate how our reproductive systems are policed
fighting for that world is feminist
fighting for a world in which we do have choice is feminist
but the having of the baby
the not having of the baby
all that shit no
we have matriarchal bloodlines that go back to forever
forever and ever and ever and come along in van patriarchy start wars
create climate change through greed
dictate the terms on which women have babies
so that they're forced to have babies
and then we turn around create the conditions in which women turn around
and judge each other for having babies
that my friends is patriarchy at work stay safe